welcome to heads up with stapes the show
where I chase down Team PokerStars pros
to find out more about their lives away
from the table then we play a little
heads up of our own hey guys welcome to
heads up with stapes and today we were
at the penthouse apartment a PokerStars
team pro olivia marie now this might be
my last chance to sort of get in good
with Liv and I know that she loves rock
music so that's what today's show is all
about you know hello Olivia okay how are
you doing I'm doing very well how are
you good what the hell you like that the
dead no I think I mean I'm very much
alive every time I see you yeah anyway
we're here with heads up what same talk
a little rock music today absolutely
this is the living room I apologize for
the lack of flooring I'm getting it
changed because the person lifted before
liked things to look like old lady
things and I don't so series the middle
of some stuff you're not in the middle
of like the worst run you've ever had
got the big TV here yeah what kind of
shows do you like Arrested Development I
think is the funniest show on TV I
actually think we should go outside for
green this smell is killing me so if
this is a kind of an awesome view that
you have here thank you very much
I want to rattle off a bunch of music
questions for you just all yes or no
answers can you play an instrument yes
have you ever dated a musician ever been
in a band yes are you more attracted to
someone if they are a musician yes have
you ever played in front of a large
crowd kind of okay have you ever been
pulled up on stage by the band Steel
Panther yes have you ever party with
Metallica have you ever won an
air-guitar contest tell me the story
about Metallica I met them through
another rocker friend Scotty and Finn
anthrax who plays a bit of poker and he
was like oh Metallica in town we're
going out for dinner want to call me
okay friends
they threw that party go it 9:00 in the
morning did the hotel room get destroyed
baby noise welcome to all night of mine
on so what do you say we go play guitar
hero whoever lays down the best score an
electric shock guitar hero wins the
losers got to perform an open mic night
there's one thing I didn't really tell
you about Guitar Hero by itself too easy
throw a little a little monkey wrench
we'll fly in the ointment a little
caveats if you will we're gonna be
playing guitar hero while we receive
electric shocks let's wire each other up
huh when I play guitar girl my friends
call me cool dad because I look like the
guy the old man in the basement trying
too hard like any plane
totally strong
that's all yeah big okay I gotta go do
some stand-up comedy
so I am very very proud to introduce all
the way from Los Angeles California
Joe I just recently moved to London for
my job I have not seen my new apartment
yet
my company says it's very nice they're
putting up in a place called council
estates do we have people living you
can't hear at all anyone yeah thank you
okay out in traffic you have these signs
that say camera enforcement and next to
the Cameron forces and there's a picture
of a camera but it's not like the
universal picture of a camera it's not
like this where with a little flash on
it is an old-timey accordion-style
camera if there's a guy on the corner in
a top hat with a blanket over his head
twisting his moustache holding a
phosphorescent flash waiting for
speeders maybe that's not the best way
to catch people so unbelievable that
didn't work out as a joke or as a thing
very warm and welcoming loving
environment here actually I got laid
last night thank you yes
I had unprotected sex with an old lady
she gave me hearing aids oh my god
that's my time
that is it what ends up with stapes
thank you very much
be sure to subscribe to heads-up the
stapes on YouTube and of course you can
always tweet out as a stagette
speech you Olivia Wow alright that was
for you smell you later everybody join
us next time on heads up with stapes